hey everyone its Johanna here when it
comes to staying healthy and fit
exercising only contributes 20% and your
food in fact contributes 80% to your
success hence picking the right food
when you do your grocery shopping is
crucial to maintaining a healthy weight
so if you are new to eating a healthy
and well-balanced diet or if you like to
clean up your food cupboard here are
several food categories that you need to
have in your grocery list before you do
your grocery shopping it is important to
first roughly plan your meals out for
the week if you go without knowing what
you want and just buy whatever that
seems to appeal to you chances are you
will end up with more junk foods than
wholesome food second do not ever shop
when you are hungry everything will seem
more appealing and chances are you will
end up with more foods that you don't
need especially junk foods so here's a
basic healthy grocery shopping guide you
can start with the first food category
that you need is complex cups or starchy
cups complex Cup is essential as part of
your meals to stabilize blood sugar
level and to keep your energy level up
this should make a quarter of your meal
some of the examples include quinoa
oatmeal brown rice couscous whole wheat
pasta
sweet potato high-fiber cereal whole
grain bread and more so ask yourself
what are you having for breakfast are
you having oatmeal whole grain bread or
cereals what about lunch and dinner are
you having brown rice bread quinoa or
pasta chances are you can buy a huge
selection of dried complex carbs because
they will last and store for a long time
second food category your protein
consuming protein in your meals will
help to keep you satisfied for much
longer and to reduce cravings again this
should make a quarter of your meals
choose three to four different varieties
some of my favorite proteins include
salmon chicken eggs and canned beans
other examples include any other fish
seafood red meat which should be
consumed occasionally as they are higher
in saturated fat tofu tempeh canned tuna
protein bars or protein powder and more
so if you are a busy person and have
very the time to prep meals I would
suggest to buy more easy to go protein
such as canned tuna canned beans and
protein bar this way when you are tight
on time you will still be able to pack
in your protein and to curb hunger third
food category vegetables buy them in
abundance this should make out the
largest part of your grocery shopping
and also your meals they are extremely
low in calories high in fiber
hence help to curb hunger and it is hard
to over eat them buy as many varieties
as you want and have at least two green
leafy vegetables some of my favorite
vegetables which you have seen a lot in
my recipes include broccoli carrots
spinach lettuce canned tomatoes onions
and garlic to enhance the flavors I tend
to buy more frozen vegetables because
they last longer and they are much
cheaper in price as well shop according
to your budget buy seasonal fruits or
vegetables and buy them in box if you
can't finish them you can always chop
and freeze them up so nothing will ever
go to waste
this leads onto my next food category
fruits for fruits I would encourage you
to buy either fresh fruits or frozen
fruits try to avoid canned fruits as
most of them are soaked in syrup hence
high amount of added sugar you can buy
frozen fruits or freeze fresh fruits to
make healthy and delicious smoothies
another tip is to always keep fresh
fruit at home in your bag or at work so
when you need a quick sugar boost you
will have a fruit to turn to food
category number five is your snacks yes
they are extremely important and should
be part of your grocery list your snacks
can either be the key to
achieve your goal or it can be the
culprit to your weight gain whatever
snacks you buy you will eat them so
choose your snacks wisely some of the
healthy snacks to go for include nuts or
seeds dried fruits such as apricot or
goji berries fresh fruits whole grain
crackers you get vegetables popcorn and
more snacks you shoot by occasionally or
avoid storing at home especially if you
know you have the tendency to indulge a
little too far include chips chocolate
bars especially those loaded with sugar
sweets cakes biscuits pastries ice cream
basically any processed food which are
high in calories and loaded with fat and
sugar my advice is not to buy them as
part of your weekly grocery shopping
personally if I crave for a naughty food
I would then go out and buy one this
takes more effort and reduces the chance
of me indulging in them on a regular
basis the next food category is what I
call flavors just think about how do you
intend to cook and add flavors into your
food because the last thing you want is
to eat a plain piece of chicken or fish
yet at the same time we do not want to
add lots of high-calorie sauce just to
flavor our chicken which makes it from
being a really healthy meal to an
unhealthy meal the best way to add
flavors into your cooking without adding
extra calories sodium or fat is to use
spices I love my spices I would say at
least choose 2 to 3 different varieties
what I have here are ground cumin chili
powder dried mixed herbs and dried
parsley so use these hubs to dry rub it
into your chicken breast then roast it
grill it or sear it healthy food will
never be boring or tasteless again other
essential flavors to have include olive
oil 1 calorie spray especially if you do
a lot of baking natural sweeteners such
as honey stevia or maple syrup lemon and
peanut butter or fruit gel for your
morning toast and oatmeal and the final
food
degree dreams we should be drinking at
least 2.5 to 3 litres of water a day and
do very mind that this include other
fluids as well drinking water on its own
can be plain and boring to most people
so do consider adding other healthy
drinks to meet your daily fluid
requirements this includes green tea or
any other tea and coffee do drink them
in moderation especially if you are
sensitive to caffeine other drinks you
can include our lemon juice apple cider
vinegar hot chocolate sir look or any
other milk and more again consume them
in for duration as they can add to your
daily calorie intake drinks you should
not store at home are fruit juices as
they tend to have a lot of added sugar
soda drinks energy drinks and alcohol if
you really have to consume them in
absolute minimal so the next time you
plan to do your grocery shopping follow
these three steps first has this 7 food
category list with you second roughly
plan your meals for the week even better
not plan them in detail but write a
grocery list and stick by it
grocery shopping should be exciting
because you are buying foods to feed
your body so nourish your body with the
best foods because you deserve it on the
best for new Fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do you follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys